a hectic morning for a group of senior
citizens here in the valley their
apartment building caught fire before
dawn forcing them out of their homes
this happened at the arthur mccants
manor that is in a building near eastern
and washington luckily though no one
injured but now many of those tenants
need a place to live hector mejia live
at the scene with the latest hector good
afternoon
hey there the american red cross is here
helping those who are left without a
home investigators believe the fire
started outside on the balcony of that
second floor the person inside told
investigators they were out there
smoking before calling in a night
i was scared
i was scared i didn't know where with
the fire olivia holman is pointing at
the fire that brought almost 100
firefighters to arthur mccann's manor by
eastern and washington the 75-year-old
says she was woken up by loud smoke
alarms around 3 30 a.m then this
screaming fire fire fire the low income
apartment complex houses senior citizens
holmen says many have a disability some
people's in wheelchairs
walkers and stuff
lucky god bless me
to still be able to walk and start so i
had to leave my cats and grab my purse
with all my ideas stuff like that just
in case something happens to me everyone
evacuated safely crews controlled the
flames quickly keeping the fire around
the area where it all started as people
waited they were given blankets and
welcomed into a warm rtc bus lucky god
got us
and we got out
and that is the good news this afternoon
everyone got out ok the fire department
meanwhile estimates the damage to cost
around 150 thousand dollars hector mejia
reporting live local now hector curious
you know that bystander that the victim
there she talked about how many folks
that live in that apartment complex or
elderly they have a disability they're
in wheelchairs whatever the case may be
so how did firefighters get them out so
safely what were they able to do
yeah you know most managed to just walk
out and get out on their own but a bit
of a dramatic scene for some the
hallways were filled with so much smoke
some had to be rescued by a ladder
john
just a sign of some of the good work by
our local firefighters hector thank you
very much now we also spoke with las
vegas fire about how the building's
structured the way it was built actually
helped with their efforts this morning
with the doors closed they were like
sheltering in place
it was probably a blessing in the skies
in that
by those people staying in their units
they didn't go into the smoke field
hallway which could have caused more
injuries so it worked out really well
firefighters say if you ever find
yourself in a fire like this and the
hallway is engulfed in smoke and flames
shut yourself in a room keep the smoke
and those flames at bay